okay well welcome to our second lecture
of the night and in celebration again of
the match between Fabi and Magnus I'd
like to show another game which I think
again highlights some of the struggles
that Fabi has to go through in order to
be at Magnus
so Bobby is also white in this game and
as in our last game
Magnus plays well a controversial move
f5 right and so again you know one thing
we're gonna be looking for in this match
is what openings Magnus is gonna throw
at Fabi is he gonna try to play more
mainline stuff where Fabi I think is the
best prepared player in the world now
other people don't believe that but I
think when I think about somebody's
opening preparation I think Fabi is the
absolute best and we see it here - he's
welling he can play d4 efore he can play
anything and throw all kinds of things
at you and what he normally does when
he's playing people who aren't Magnus
right is he thinks about which opening
there he wants most wants to face
whether he's gonna play e4 d4 and here
it's more like you know it's very hard
to prepare for Magnus very hard okay
there's a lot of good moves here for
white but Magnus or Fabi plays the
traditional g3 okay and probably at this
point had no idea what kind of Dutch
Magnus was going to play but Magnus now
opts for the stone wall
alright let me just go on a little
diatribe against the Dutch alright so
the problem with the Dutch is f5 is not
a move which is going to help you
develop your pieces d4e 493 those are
all going to help you develop your
pieces f5 does not do that and it's
making it's going to make your King
obviously weaker but getting to that
King is often a tricky subject and we'll
get to that question a little bit if you
want to make a claim though that the
move f5 is reasonable I think you have
to say well my rook is one day gonna
land on f8 and then it's gonna be a good
move right I think that's that's got to
be your mindset once you go crazy and
play f5 alright so here we go d5 castles
Bishop d6 b3 Queenie SEP so this is an
ancient variation where black is with
Queenie 70s developed the Queen but he's
also prevented the exchange of the good
piece on d6 right now I think this is
definitely a great game to think about
good pieces and bad pieces and the first
obvious thing is the bishop on c8 is
poor right that the Stonewall gets kind
of a bad rap but this position let's
let's honor it a second and say this is
very hard to crack it really is a wall
and the thing that we should first
observe is that this bishop on g2 is
problematic it's not a terrible piece or
anything but it's just hidden what is
literally a wall right so you can trust
it to the other game we just looked at
with a pawn on c6 now there's also a
pawn on d5 and the pawn on f5 makes it
so that we it's difficult anyway to play
E for to open the position
one thing that's kind of interesting
about chess I think is that time is
always important right and so the old
Soviet rule is to say that three tempi
are worth a pawn and that's a good rule
to remember because it gives you a way
to translate the material L material
world of chess the dimension of chess to
that of time may gives you a way to
translate it but a funny thing is like
time matters more the more the position
is open so it's not always the same
value and in this position I'm making
this whole spiel just to say it doesn't
matter as much that black is going to
loot loose a has lost some time making
all these pawn moves and he makes
another pawn move now with b6
excuse me Queen e7 Bishop b2 b6 and I
would say this is the a new new ish way
of playing the Dutch when I was a kid
everybody played like castles followed
by Knight d7 followed by some kind of 94
and then hoping to do some kind of magic
either with E 5 pushing the pawn to e5
at some point or Bishop d7 to e8 and
then somehow magically over to h5 right
now the reason b6 seems a little bit
fishy right is because that diagonal
seems like it's gonna be weak when I'm
say diagonal I mean the G to a8 diagonal
if I knew how to make an arrow and make
that arrow but I don't know how to write
there but I think one thing we should
just say strategically is that the
bishop will be reasonable on b7 and then
at some point White has to worry about
black planks e5 and I think that would
be part of the story of this game is
that you know c5 is going to be in the
air
okay Knight d2 Bishop B 795 castles now
let's talk about it the bishop on b2 is
working well by supporting the knight on
e5 and this is basically a system that
was invented a long time ago to try to
get something out of this stone wall and
the knight is so annoying and the idea
is that if you ever take it my bishop on
b2 will gain in strength it'll gain in
scope there's a lot of classic games
where you know Bishop e5 happens de5 and
then some kind of a you know white works
to push even the e pawn to open up the
bishop on b2 so this is like an old
tried-and-true method of making some
sense of the position because as you see
it's not easy for white to break through
it all okay rook c1 I'm sure there was
other moves that Bobby could have played
Queen c2 III all these things were
possible and one beautiful thing about
the next couple moves is it's here that
both players are going to develop their
strategic sense of what's going on in
the position right and when I was a kid
it was basically the whole I'd the whole
reason you might want to play the Dutch
is that you did things like 94 and then
maybe you dreamed of g5f for something
you just you wanted to come at the King
right but there's a lot of flexibility
the way Magnus is plane is here and he
does I think a nice plan
he plays a5 and the point is to say you
put your rook on c1 so now I'm gonna
make you think about a4 at some point I
don't have to play it right away but I'm
gonna make you think about a4
and I'm gonna say also that I'm gaining
some interesting space on the queenside
so let's do two more moves and think
about the position
III nine a six alright
I am sure everyone in this room has had
positions that feel like this and by
that I just mean like there's a lot of
stuff going on and it's very hard to get
a grip on how to play the position the
best advice I have is that you should
begin by just kind of doing a basic
evaluation of the strength of the pieces
right and we know that the bishop on g2
is hitting a wall
we know that the bishop on d6 is his
best piece our knight on e5 is working
our bishop on b2 is working and then we
were noticed oh it's the night on d2 is
a little funny right one thing I think
we should see though is we should ask
like well what is black maybe intending
and that's where it gets really tricky
because honestly Black has a lot of
things I think he could think about the
biggest one is at some point to simply
play C 5 but we also have to worry about
a four maybe even B 5 all these things
are ways for black to push us okay
possible sure definitely in general just
the idea of grabbing the a file after
rook c1 is I'm sure part of the
motivation behind playing a5 and here's
the funny thing it's like it feels like
Black has the options but it's I still
want to believe that Bobby's better here
right because the bishop on b7 is funny
and all of that okay one thing we should
notice is it would be nice to dominate
the knight on a six by playing a three
unfortunately it's not so easy for us to
do that because he's got it covered
right and in general I think what what
Bobby would like to do is control the
black pieces because it's not
immediately clear how we're gonna get
through my it's is a long-term struggle
that we have in front of us like I think
a lot of the games that we're gonna get
in the World Championship another thing
I want to mention about the Dutch is the
black King on g8 is fairly safe right
now but something that has invariably
happen to anybody who's played the Dutch
is stuff gets loosened up right in the
course of the game things become a
little soft and if a couple files open a
couple pieces go open imagine even a
heavy end game with rooks and rooks and
queens that King on g8 will be
substantially worse than our King on g1
a great example actually of a recent
game where the opponent's king was
weaker in a heavy endian was this
beautiful game from the Olympiad were
Fabi played mama DRF it was a big game
and beautiful play against the weakened
King so one piece that we should
evaluate really is also the Kings and so
one reason to believe I think that white
is better is because our King is
but again that's like it's a far-off
abstract thing it's not important right
now okay I want to say that if I was
playing this position I probably
certainly would have done something like
this Knight f3 and why would I have done
it just because I've seen other people
do it
that's the only reason right we're just
within a some kind of vague intention of
playing Knight d3 and then maybe
bringing the other night into e5
sitting on him right that kind of thing
now there's a couple I think Knight of
three is a fine move but the things that
I'm sure Fabi was worried about our two
things one is black I assume can play c5
right now and then you got to worry
about how you're gonna meet that the
other thing is like well when you play
Knight b3 Knight d3 to reorganize your
Knights night before can then happen
right and then you know you got a
problem I you know there's this pawn on
a2 and how do you want to deal with it
yeah so Fabi played I guess it's a good
move but it is definitely nuts and I
wouldn't have thought yeah I wouldn't
have even thought about it right after
he let's talk about f3 actually well I
used to play a lot of this is in the
pre-computer age I used to play a lot of
games both blitz and otherwise against
Grandmaster dmitriyevich and he loved to
play this touching this kind of thing
against me and I would always play I
would always be like oh I won't play f3
e4 I'm gonna bust you up son we're gonna
come get you right but it's like it's
it's usually bad it's usually a bad
thing because now first of all blacks
King is just as good as my king I gave
away that advantage right the next thing
is now my bishop is even worse than it
already
right now if I play e4 it feels good but
even if he doesn't do anything right if
you just lets it sit there I'm not sure
I've helped myself any like none of my
pieces got better right now I'm sure
there's certain positions that will want
to do it I'm just saying it's a bad
instinct it's a bad instinct yeah and
that took me forever to learn because
that guy beat me again and again and
every time if three four I'm gonna come
get you I'm gonna come get you you know
no boat back bullet back okay so here we
are we have this position anyone want to
guess what Fabi plate we're have a
strong feeling about what what you do
what's that a form that's injured why
why do you want to do a four oh to stop
him from playing a four that's a thought
but no notice if you play a four you're
giving black this beautiful hole forever
on before to sink his teeth into right
it's important to think about actually
because when you think about whites
advantage and I'm sure Fabi had this in
his mind let's go back to our beginning
position we should say that black has
two totally reasonable pieces right
here's the bishop on d6 that's a
beautiful piece that's a beautiful piece
the knight on f6 is also totally great
some day to land on e4 that's what the
Dutch players always do there go over
the landed on e4 but the knight on a6 is
bad and the bishop on b7 at the very
least needs some help with a move like
c5 right so a4 is a good example of how
you can lose control over the pieces
right because now that before it comes
it's doing something kind of important a
lot of things actually hitting d3
hitting d5 and c6 is also a nice thing
to be hitting so it's an example of the
threat being greater than the execution
now that was something names of it said
and honestly I read that thing over and
over again I didn't understand what he
was talking about the idea is you're
afraid of a4
right that's the threat in your mind and
so in order to face that threat or do
away with it you play a four and then
that's an example of the threat was
greater than the execution right because
they for itself wouldn't have been
nearly as cool as getting the be four
square like this okay
all right let's let's look Donna see I
stared that the the ninety to move some
of you I know weren't at the last
lecture but there was another funny
night move that Bobby did in that move I
immediately understood this one I
literally stared at it for half an hour
and I think I get it okay might be one
no I don't think so
I think controlling a three is one nice
thing yeah alright it's very complicated
let me I'm gonna no I might I might get
this wrong but I'm gonna try my best to
explain this in the game black does not
play c5 but that doesn't mean that Fabi
wasn't worried about it and I think one
thing about the night the b1 first thing
to realize is that one key difference I
see between good players and great
players because the really good players
are sensitive to their poorly placed
pieces right you especially in the at
the I don't know under 2200 level you
see players do what I call playing with
their pretty pieces that means they move
their pieces around that can do
something and then just let their other
pieces sit because they don't know what
to do with them right so night b1 is an
attempt to fix the night on d2 that was
dominated by the pawn on d5 right and I
think okay it does a couple things
one thing it does is if you ever play
Knight before I can play Knight c3 but
that's not the main thing I think the
main thing is if black tries to fix his
Bishop with c5
that my knight can then come to c3 and
on c3 it will pressure d5 excuse me I
would get that wrong
it will pressure d5 and it will enable
Knight b5 so do two things right and I
think in general c5 is the plan that
Magnus was playing for right so Knight
be one it's funny move but in a way one
way to talk about it even would be to
say by making c5 at least a little bit
disagreeable I'm either getting the
Knight to c3 will be strong after c5
because notice it's not strong now if
you go to c6 is dominated by the ball on
c6 so if he doesn't play c5 the logic
could be well then the bishop on b7
remains bad because the bishop be sevens
only hope right is to play c5 that has
that option and remember also the option
of hitting d5 because the d5 point will
also be weak once you place C 5 and then
we're aiming for some thing where I want
to explode the position and say your
Kings worse yeah now that's that's deep
chess that's really deep chess
alright there are a number of things
that Magnus could have played here and
his next move like in the same way that
night b1 shocked me his next move
shocked me as well and I'm not sure I
well I think that night b1 is in fact
the genius move I'm not sure Magnus's
next move is a genius move but it's
definitely interesting
he has a lot of different moves 97 is
definitely a move I think B 5 is
actually kind of interesting he maybe he
can get away with a four let me show you
what he did he committed a crime and
traded off his best piece this is a
crime yeah this is a chess crime well
that's the thing so this is the thing
we're gonna be watching for is when he
commits this crime so are we gonna be
able to arrest him okay so let's think
about it the knight on e4 was gonna go
there probably anyway but the dream is
that I guess if that we're aiming for a
move like a four and that in particular
our Knights the when I say our I mean
the Black Knights will be able to target
weaknesses in the white position
I think that's it's a totally valid
question and so you're asking why not
just play 94 first I think one possible
answer is that now if I play f3 you
can't go to c5 still your move is still
valid because you could just say okay
thank you thank you for your f3 write
possible yeah no I think 94 isn't
necessarily a bad move and honestly I
wouldn't if I was playing back I
wouldn't even think about Bishop b5 it
wouldn't even cross my mind you know so
I would definitely think about 94 as
well you you might be onto something if
I understand you right um the one thing
that is a strategy in the positions like
this that's honestly even deeper than I
have the ability to play for but I know
as a strategy is that if I get your
knight on b1 then you can sincerely ask
the question how do you are you ever
gonna crack me open because the Knights
the guy that can widdle around and do
stuff the bishops themselves they need
help to open the position and without
the night it's gonna be really hard to
open the black position so I think that
actually it's kind of in the back of the
mind of what's going on in this in this
plan when 94 would definitely
controversial okay
many different moves that white could
have played he played Queen e2 it makes
a lot of sense and now here I'm going to
guess that Fabi thought he had this move
under control and now a four comes
don't take it no you don't want it
taking it would be a bad move right then
the knight comes to c5 and everything
starts falling but here I feel like Fabi
capitulates bi and what I mean by that
is to say he convinces himself that he
don't no longer can play for an
advantage and that he feels like he's
been outplayed which is weird because
the guy just did all this crazy stuff
right the movie played and this is what
I mean by capitulation is Knight c3
which is a natural move but it gives
black to beautiful options both of which
seem fine to me right the one I would
play actually if I was black I'm sure of
it as I would play a three and then I I
could have be four for life maybe it's
still roughly equal but I just feel
pretty good about having my pawn on a3
you mean after a three
oh you mean what he what he actually did
we're gonna come to that yeah it's
actually really this is one of the other
really interesting things that happens
so here's a moment I guess I would say
is that when when Fabi plays a knight c3
we're gonna get moments like this in the
match to it's essentially a moment where
Fabi is saying okay now I'm saying the
positions about equal after Knight c3
and I'm just kind of holding equality
arguably I'm playing for a draw but I'm
no longer you know playing for a win the
move to play for when I guess would have
been Bishop a3 and it gets pretty hairy
though and you would have to be ready
the idea is this that you for c5 and
then say oh that was the square your
knight one to go through and then play
f3 Knight g5 and I'm not exactly sure
what to think of this position but the
argument is that the knight on d5 is out
of play and that if you ever play Knight
f7 right let's just for kicks a 92 I'm
not saying that's the best move but if
you play Knight f7 that's something like
f4 it's gonna happen and then your
knight is truly a little bit problematic
right so in any case I think that was
Bobby's attempt and it it's actually
interesting to think about the move f3
because it kind of actually says this
may be psychologically interesting
because there's another point in the
game where he doesn't want to play f3
and Bishop a3 the only way that move
makes any sense is to say oh I'm playing
f3 next cuz Carlsen would love to play
c5 to open up the bishop you know thank
you very much it feels like a tempo okay
so this is what happens at night c3
he takes it at the very least it's
active and the rook on c1 is not active
right Queen before
and now we're gonna see that Fabi needs
to take the knight on e4 and why is that
because if you play Queen c2 Knight c5
is coming and then we're already in a
little bit of grief right okay so Queen
before takes and I think you asked the
question about like what is it which way
do you intend and here's another funny
thing when I was a kid the Stonewall
people they always took that way that
would like well that's my rook friend
and it's hitting your f2 pawn hello it's
a very interesting moment so is it
instructive to because when we think
about that Bishop on g2 one of the nice
things that Magnus does here is he says
I'm gonna take with the D pawn and well
let's ask ourselves a little like that
see that's weird but the idea I think is
that if you took with the F pawn the
bishop at the very least it gets to go
to h3 and then you have to do something
the babysit the pawn right so the bishop
then at least has it as a job of some
kind right
and so d e4 is all about making the
pieces bad and I'll say this just from
my own personal experience both teaching
and playing is that I wish someone had
told me earlier in my life that the
pawns are just they're that pawns aren't
actually people they think they're
people but they're not actually people
and they're more like the scenery around
which your actual people move and
conduct their business right but the
pause themselves are not forget the
pawns right don't think about pawn
structures if you're gonna think about
pawn structures think about it in terms
of like which pieces work well in which
structures but don't just think about it
like oh this is a good structure and
that's a bad structure because that
messed with my head
I read at some book when I was a kid
talking about good pawn structures and
No depends on the pieces depends where
the pieces are the pawns where - no
don't talk to me about the pawns well
right that set me back years yeah I
don't want to hear about pawn sales I
want to hear about where the pieces are
in the skeleton right okay so now we get
a pretty forcing line here that I'm sure
both of them saw and this is the one of
things actually by the way that
separates they're really strong from
people like me were they I almost
guarantee it when he played D take C for
Magnus saw my good seven moves out here
okay so here we go
Queen c2 Knight c5 Bishop c3 Queen b3
takes Knight takes rook be one night c5
there would be six nine a for rook b7
Knight c3
yeah he definitely saw that on move 18
where I moved 24 now
okay so complete transformation of the
position it's interesting you know when
you look at it from here you have to ask
yourself well how do I feel about this
do I think is good for me as black do I
think it's good for white you know it's
all kind of out there as a question on
the surface I can imagine Fabi saying
something like well yes my bishop is bad
but at least my rook let's call it let's
say that my rook is up a tempo right in
the sense it is active it's a good rook
yeah that's a good night absolutely
absolutely
a good thing about this Knight right is
that he's doing a lot and know it's hard
any way to dislodge it and a good quote
that I like a lot is that Knights are
really good at exploiting local
weaknesses and what that means is that
the bishop is a runner and it does a lot
of things it probably is a better piece
you know when you get into an open board
the bishop will just control more than a
knight ever camp it control 1112 squares
the night you know the most he's got is
eight but the knight does both colors
and that's an important thing in a
position like this the knight can really
bounce around and do all kinds of things
whether it's the f2 pawn or the f3
square right it can do more than one
thing and that's what makes it so
powerful especially in combination with
a rook all right now this next move
let's say two moves I'm very critical of
what Fabi did uh-huh and this is an
example of where you forget about your
pawns all right any idea what white you
think white you play f3 yeah we don't
care about our double pawns on e3 and e5
get the thing open that man needs some
freedom he needs to do something right
yeah I think after f3 yeah I don't know
it's roughly equal is hard to say who's
better that kind of thing but if you do
not play f3 well then I then then I'm
worried
so if Fabi does this first move is not
its first planning ways I don't think
terrible he says let's play rookie 7 and
this will kind of force rookie 8 and
I'll like undeveloped your rook on a 8
right I've undeveloped it
what should you play now though you
better play f3 you better play a 3 he
plays rook a 1 and now rook e8 happens I
still think you better play f3 but it's
good it's starting to get a little hokey
in fact f3 already item I'm not sure I
believe in it anymore because of things
like rook d3 so already it's getting a
little dangerous it's still not over
okay but here it gets it's starting to
get weird bishop f1 very simple move by
Magnus now c5
right the bishop is stuffed and it's a
funny thing about these kinds of
positions right is if you've got a bad
piece in the end game it's a really
terrible thing like here's an example by
the way I think it's important to not
consider pawns people even though that
sounds terrible right is that when you
look at a position like this I think
it's very helpful to forget about the
pawns a little bit and say there's
really three actors we got a king a rook
in a knight
it's three against three right and White
has one bad piece with the bishop on f1
now what I want you to also see is the
King on g1 is also not the greatest guy
he's also in a little bit of a cage and
one thing I really think helped my chest
I think will help anybody's chest is it
when you think about these positions
where you have a bad piece it will help
you play other phases of the game much
better and what I mean by that is a lot
of times I see beginning level players I
see them not feel the urgency of their
bad pieces and in the opening it's not
as big of a deal because there's like
eight guys there's eight guys on the
court at the beginning of the game right
so if you have one in eight who's bad
it's not that bad of a ratio but if
you've got here one out of three it's
it's gonna feel in just a little bit
almost as if blacks up a piece right so
again that's just my own personal thing
I guess that end games taught me it's
not it's not the end game learning the
end game isn't just about you know
learning some algorithm to do the bishop
and night mate or some other fancy
positions those are important but what
you really get from good endgame players
or positions like this where you're
focused on the activity of the pieces
because that's what it's going to come
down to in a position
like this okay now here I guess is where
Fabi kind of loses his mind
it's hard to control the night the night
is going to hop all around and it's hard
to contain him because your Bishop's bad
you're kind of playing down a piece but
there's no reason we should really lose
this position Fabi plays rook a three
and there's going to be definitely
trouble after rook a three
I was thinking Brooke c1 but even here
you know the rook one reason to say you
know I don't like rook c1 is the rook is
obviously not as active on c1 as it was
on a1 and you can even feel it in the
way Fabi clearly intended you know did
get say oh my rooks good here right so
you can feel that in that decision to
play rook a3 instead you have a question
you could definitely think about rook a
five let's take a look so let's say rook
d2 you won't take it let's try taking it
91
no sure let's go for the other puncture
check in order to get my pawn you have
to help my King out a little bit okay
let's try it out
so we're gonna get a situation now where
you're gonna try to write you're gonna
try to run the pawns and I'm gonna try
to make you alright he's gonna try to
meet you that's what he wants here rook
d6 okay that's a good move let's say
rook c2
no the night's hang the night's hanging
on an f2 right yeah I think though we're
just gonna go back our King does things
okay
Knight g4 but the night that's covered
yeah that's covered yeah it's a bummer
here c6 all right now either rook C one
night h2 or 93 they all look pretty good
Knight h2 would threaten mate but then
you could maybe try Bishop g2 right so
alright let's just play the mundane move
and see what happens I guess Rick c1 is
the threat see Sam well I can't I can
take it right I think it's a fair
question
Rick a5 is definitely a question to ask
and I'm sure Fabi was looking at that
kind of thing but the thing to realize
with that night in the rook is it's not
just that they're gonna grab pawns they
want to mate you and steal your Bishop
right let's take a look
rook a3 Nightbeat one rook a 192 and
Fabi must have said okay Bishop b2 I'm
okay
I got it covered okay everybody can
imagine feeling you got it covered here
right check it out so the last several
moves black has been playing with the
intention of having the bishop on e to
be bad and so the next move is
aesthetically beautiful and
strategically pleasing here we go
Knight f3 and so here's the problem for
white if you take it now we're gonna
make a totally different claim we're
gonna say your king is bad yeah we're
gonna say the King is bad and because
the King is bad well now the rook is
gonna come in and start doing things or
you play King g2 and then take the pawn
on e5 you lose the point both are
unpleasant in hindsight maybe Fabi
should have let him take the pawn on e5
a ch3 good that's what was played h5
you love that rook air-five okay but now
I can go check and rook f1 okay yeah and
this is this would be a similar thing to
the game where what I want you to see is
there's no way out for the King because
the second you play g4 I'm gonna I'm
gonna play h4 myself so your King can't
get out good yeah rook e1 - yeah I have
a lot there's a lot of problems here for
white but the first thing I need to just
cement my advantage is to make sure that
King doesn't get out and let's take a
look out Fabi plays he tries to bust out
of it takes takes h4 and this is truly
where Magnus is evil now Magnus is evil
- this is terrible
okay g5 s an interesting question but
what's gonna happen now the king is
going to not only win your pawn but he's
going to get his king active as well
sure King king f7 was would have been a
similar thing maybe King f7 stronger but
right the king will become active and
we're still playing for mate - right
it's a reasonable question though g5
because you're right if black plays g5
then we're in the box right Fabi comes
up with a pretty cool idea
King age - rook d2 King age 3 g5 and he
plays it great let's call it a trick
with E for
I'll give you guys a second What evil
trick is Fabi planning okay very good so
let's show the variation what's your
name I say it again paddy yeah let's
look at the variation that addy proposes
this is beautiful and then look at this
oh that's painful
ouch it shows a level of resourcefulness
right I mean you've got nothing else in
this position unfortunately Magnus now
just goes back
it's a good attempt because not only did
you have the stalemate trick but now he
brings the King deaf seven and now he
gets he does win the pawn on f3
now notice we're gonna the again the
pawn structure is gonna change right but
a key feature is going to remain and
that's that the King on h3 is remaining
poor snip check over and it's it's an
interesting thing for these guys this is
I think this is I think they recognize
that this is over for us mortals of
course we'd play on thinking that we
could hold this thing rookie three
rookie for f3 c4 so the problem is not
just the past C pawn but the fact that
my king is going to be stronger 33
okay seven d8
so the King on d8 prevents the rook from
getting behind the pawn on f3 was
threatened so King G to c3 we're okay
for you got to come back to play rook c4
right sure let's give a check and now if
you go to g1 then c2 rook d1 will win
instantly so you got to go back to your
miserable hole on h3 c2 rook c4 and now
we're just gonna wait because you can't
do anything
rook c5 rook F to Bobby plays that
forward now it's desperation rook f3
snip and he resigned right now it's
gonna be two pest funds and that's what
happened in the last game too right it's
too fast fun that's when you resign I
think you know to me I'm really I'm a
huge fabbi fan but I think what these
games show it actually to me were a lot
of fab ease brilliance moves like 92 and
night b1 but also showed I think you
know how amazing it would be to beat
Magnus and also the kind of positions
that he's gonna need to outplay him in
right these positions where Magnus maybe
gives him a little you know gives him a
little to play with and he has to win
with a space advantage which is so hard
to do
yeah and one thing I'll say about Fabi
that I think is kind of interesting I
think all the players who have grown up
you know in the last 10 years have all
actually been most influenced more than
anybody by Carlsen himself and Carlsen
obviously very good at playing technical
positions like this but also doing this
thing that I see Fabi doing really well
where he's able to play positions just
move from move and slowly
outplay the opponent in ways that you
look at it you're like wait his opponent
just all did natural moves how did this
happen and it kind of like this is like
what how do we how did we go from this
position at the beginning to this one
you know we got here at a four boom and
Knight c3 really is a move which says
okay I'm white and I'm just holding the
balance yeah and I guess you know
multiple occasions where Fabi did not
play f3 that was to me the big deciding
feature of what happens later
[Music]